>>Well, good morning or good afternoon depending
on where you are.
We have three of us here from India, Pakistan,
and Bangladesh.
My name is Rahul Bajaj.
I'm a member of Parliament, member of our
house which is called Lok
Sabha in India.
And Chairman of the Bajaj Group, including
companies like Bajaj Auto
which manufactures motorcycles.
We are here in Davos, freezing temperatures
from 5 degrees below to
14 degrees below centigrade.
We three are good friends.
And especially Mr. -- sorry.
Mr. Dawood and I have known each other for
more years than I remember.
Maybe he'll tell you when he speaks.
Maybe 15 years, maybe 20 years.
And we are all from this part of the world.
It's a continent, which India Pakistan and
Bangladesh.
We were one country, we are three countries,
we'll remain three
countries.
But the people of these countries, as far
as I'm concerned and perhaps
my good friends are concerned, are one.
We're brothers, sisters.
This is what we have been for centuries.
In 62 years, they separate us.
And our strength will come from working together.
Independent people, independent countries,
but working together
economically, politically.
There have been some difference in the past
for various reasons whether
or not good reasons.
We'll not get into that.
There's no question of who is right, who is
wrong.
We will all like to work together economically,
socially and
politically.
And once we start doing that, I hope and I
believe that my friends also
hope that, I think there's no power which
can prevent South Asia --
We don't want to be become a military power,
no.
But an economic power, a humane economic power.
We will have courts with social justice.
We will have growth, what you call inclusive
growht so this poverty,
the immense poverty in our three countries
would be substantially
reduced, if not eliminated.
And we will be proud to be Indians, Pakistanis,
and Bangladeshis.
But we will hold our heads still further high
-- not out of arrogance,
but out of pride, and say we are Indians,
we are Bangladeshis, we are
Pakistanis.
And the world will slowly starting respecting
us during the last few
years, really stand up -- not salute us.
But say hi, how are you?
And soon it is to come from that people from
the West, from the
developed world would like to come and work
in India and even settle
down and retire in India.
To all of you, and my thanks to all you of
for listening to us.
Thank you very much.
>> You have heard my friend Rahul Bajaj speak.
This is my turn, my name is Fazle H. Abed.
I have been working in rural development in
Bangladesh for 38 years,
working in education, health, rural development,
and poverty
elimination.
And over the last 7 or 8 years, I've been
working in Afghanistan,
Pakistan, Sri Lanka, Tanzania, Uganda, Southern
Sudan, Liberia, and
Sierra Leone.
Because I think the way of getting people
out of poverty, we have done
some good effective work in Bangladesh.
And some of it could be replicated in other
countries.
Not only in South Asia but also we can contribute
to Africa.
So I think that whatever we know, we want
to share with others.
And Africa, not being very fortunate in their
leadership and lacking in
institutions, we can help them in providing
institutions so that they
can also come out of poverty.
Because there is a -- there are a lot of energetic
people, very
entrepreneurial people in Africa too.
And we are trying to help them.
And my next job is going to be working in
Haiti to reforestate it, to
start a bank which will provide financial
services to small and medium
enterprises.
So I hope that all of us from South Asia will
be proud to be able to do
something for less fortunate people in Africa
and in Haiti.
So I hope that we can [INAUDIBLE].
>>My name is Hussain Dawood.
I'm Chairman of the Pakistan Poverty Alleviation
Fund, Chairman of the
[INAUDIBLE] Business Initiative and Chairman
of [INAUDIBLE] Corporation
and [INAUDIBLE] Limited.
And also the Dawood Foundation.
It's my privilege to address you today.
And we have had an opportunity here to explore
the viewpoints that have
been expressed, and I would like to say that
we too would like to say
that we too would like to be partners in development
of our
subcontinent.
And what we're trying to do is to develop
the education standards
within Pakistan, so that based on that we're
able to address some of
the critical issues which our country faces,
which is particularly the
difficulty we are having today in acts of
terrorists.
We, I believe firmly that the solution to
that lies in education.
We need a long-term solution and education
is that long-term solution.
And for that reason we are establishing [INAUDIBLE]
a which hopefully
with produce responsible entrepreneurs who
will come back into society
and try to develop and contribute towards
the realization of that
vision.
Thank you so much for giving me the option
to say a few words.